[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bonjour à tous on a plein de choses à
vous souhaiter
à vous souhaiter un bon lundi une bonne
semaine un bon 6 heures à fo sur france
2 a été derrière tout ça me fait
bafouillé vous fait prendre pour une
triste à mourir je suis bol que j'adore
rigoler et j'adore raconter ces bruits
et danser et voilà sérieux et compétents
et également
enjouée mais ses zélateurs d'ailleurs là
c'est ce qu'attendent vos clients pas
que vous soyez droits locaux compétents
et que je leur mette je remonte le moral
voilà c'est
ce qui manque en brûler les comptes au
prix ont pris les clés de chez moi en
partant et dvd clé ils ont pris un de
maison ils sont partis chez moi d'accord
ils n'ont pas le temps de tout prendre
la police vient est prêt jeddah et jeudi
mais j'étais un peu en panique s'ils
reviennent puisqu'ils ont les clés gs
que je droit est armé à bord une bombe
lacrymogène
alors juste s'ils reviennent qu'est ce
que je fais mais vous nous appelez mais
sa plus belle jambe ne rien voir trois
roumains qui sont chez moi
cet avis de recherche de la police
anglaise a eu beaucoup de succès les
milliers de commentaires ne mène à
aucune piste mais tous évoquent le
physique de johnatan cahill l'homme de
37 ans condamné pour cambriolage n'a pas
respecté les conditions liées à sa
libération mais au vu des réactions la
tâche se complique pour la police qui a
même dû supprimer la publication sur
facebook je m'excuse nom de mathieu
auprès de la communauté
non mais si j'étais général à [ __ ] de
tout j'étais comme ça c'est très bien de
quoi stocker des conneries tu l'as fait
je te le dit matthieu brasse amelia non
mais quand tu dis une connerie avoue que
tu as dit une connerie arrête de vouloir
crier plus fort que les autres et je te
dis que dans ma rue c'était ça le gang
qui était
d'abord je salue cyril hanouna qu en
train de nous regarder et j'ai demandé à
marine lançons si elle peut parce que
d'envoyer le mettre à l'antenne le sms
que m'a envoyée cyril hanouna parce
qu'il n'y a pas de raison que ce soit
moi qui porte le chapeau des blagues de
cyril hanouna qui est plutôt drôle si
j'arrive à mettre à l'antenne mais comme
elle est visuel faut vraiment qu'on
puisse la mettre à l'antenne frais
résultat la primaire populaire sont
christiane taubira qui est arrivé en
tête et lors de son discours de
remerciement elle nous a donné envie de
croire en demain car elle était tournée
vers l'avenir
[Applaudissements]
ma cheville ouvrière d'une note possible
victoire en avril 2002 et ça te dira
tout fait foirer en quelques tweets de
campagne laissant apparaître plusieurs
fautes d'orthographe
oh non pas ça pas aujourd'hui pas
maintenant pas après tout ce que tu as
fait nous acceptons le débat la
contreverse nous sommes une démocratie
moderne ces controverses du traverse
première fois on va voir le 2e
christiane taubira est alors celle là le
compteur ça c'est avec a évidemment donc
c'est quand même bien encore très
étrange et puis on a le peuple à la
troisième c'est s'il ya un tel mépris
envers la primaire populaire c'est parce
qu'elle alors parce qu'elle
vous avez vu quand même les résultats de
monsieur jadot et de monsieur mélenchon
arrive juste derrière vous donc sam en
voilà à sa montre qu' il gardait toute
l'essence n'est pas appelé les électeurs
à mes lecteurs elle n'était pas
volontaire pour être candidat à cette
primaire ils n'ont pas fait campagne ça
vous comptez faire toutes les missions
sur ce que pensent mes concurrents
fallait laisser le prince et l'interview
christelle tenir à cette apporter du
contradictoire à l'onu mais si vous
voulez étudié par les prix en malaisie
mais non c'est pas que je vais scarlett
a quitté le plateau au 6 mai ce matin
j'avais un tweet mais j'ai pas pu vous
montrer à l'antenne
j'avais cyril hanouna m'a envoyé pendant
l'émission et je pouvais pas le montrer
parce que je vous disais que c'était
vieux visuel et c'était vraiment très
drôle ce que m'a envoyée cyril je te
vois à la télé pascal c'est super ton
émission à bientôt l'équipe de crise
est arrivée avant de temps en temps de
croiser zemmour et j'aimais bien lui
dire à leur humour toujours homosexuels
de gauche alors il faisait vraiment
l'école peut rien lui dire pour lui jean
luc mélenchon 31%
31% luc mélenchon qui s'est plaint c'est
plein de
c'est lui qui a le plus la parole sur
mes amis français qui se plaignent le
plus surpris oui je sais mais c'est
toujours ceux qui ont tout vu sa parole
qui prennent leur revanche excusez-moi
chef c'est jean luc mélenchon et page en
ukraine
regard si malgré ces graves c'est ma
milliards mais ça jean marc et après the
queen sur le corps et mme y avait tout
d'abord le décret darchy au tai chi se
dit candidat amicaux mais le nouveau
président de la république italienne il
vostro père italien 12 ou nikaïa qui
tourne à caumont la volt regarde si le
chiffre est ce notre en tant que miss
pâques pour la sienne et l'osce a perfé
divertir c'est ce qu'il vous reste à
faire c'est l'hymne s'il vous plaît oui
la chose que je fais au mieux au monde
de passer un appel non ça c'est la
deuxième la première ne regarde
absolument personne
j'ai ici une soixantaine de témoignages
qui prouvent que ce que je dis
moi j'aurais parié sur la brosse à dents
moi ça m'est déjà avec ma brosse à dents
non c'était un rasoir
comme quoi tous ces trucs qui vivra
vraiment faut s'en débarrasser un rien
de vaut naturel messieurs dames sous
paul taper me mira commando compte des
vidéos history dessus boss de canal et
sociale et par thiam on perd contre
caussade magnifico ce sont les futurs
ministre des pensions va se passer un
truc en italien ça paraît franchement ça
peut se passer bien ça va être bien et
pourquoi dijon compte beaucoup plus de
célibataires que d'une part ailleurs non
parce que l'amour tarder
on l'a fait l'année dernière ça a bon
goût c'est maïs a ici on est dans le sud
c'est marseille mais béal et v mais dis
donc votre jolie petite bouille nous
rappelle quelqu'un on se serait pas déjà
croisé quelque part j'ai vu plein de
télé réalité qui - comme richie j'ai
fait les marseillais au niveau de mes
passions j'aime beaucoup lire
[Musique]
sur qu'est pas pour moi parce que oui il
peut pas m'aimer genre parce que je lis
pas je suis presbytes joie rien j'ai la
flemme je lis pas séparément trois
lectures à nous proposer cette cette
semaine
s'appelle
comment dirais-je
des patrons petits des batteries etc
merci beaucoup mais revenez via une fois
studio combat des jeunes fife amour
pour moi je sais badigeonner un poulet
mais pas l'amour en fait je ne sais pas
je suis perdu c'est un couple de vieux
ils seront dans leur lit et puis là tu
as la femme qui regarde son mari qui
écouterait mon ça fait 25 ans qu'on est
variée allez dis moi combien de fois tu
m'as trompé et là il ya un grand silence
et la femme dit raymond tu dors il fait
non j'ai pas fini de compter
[Rires]